we got shots fired for 15a as a routine
anyone sound like an automatic firearm
upstairs a negligee halfway up I see the
shop cutting program you live a halfway
up patrols is a sepia just advising
there are people down on stage left it
had just gone 10 on a Sunday night in
Las Vegas
the band stopped the gunfire stopped and
there was brief quiet in the huge crowd
and then the shooting started again in
[Applause]
the hospitality tents people hid behind
anything that looked like cover the
gunman pulled the trigger a third
[Applause]
Jason Aldean was the big-name star on
the stage at the time he was the last
act of a three-day Country Music
Festival being held just below the
Mandalay Hotel 22,000 people had come to
watch him they started shooting
everybody thought I was like fireworks
are something that first and then people
just start dropping around us and
everybody tried to stay down and every
time like a group would get up to try to
run away they'd just start shooting
again and it just kept going on
[Applause]
now I want to show folks if I'm a you
you're a little cut up it looks like
dirty I'm not kind of I basically got a
lot of people that probably have passed
aways blood on me and there's a lot of a
lot of dead bodies a lot of people were
just piling on top of whoever even if
they're bleeding or not just to stay
down so I know I have a lot of people
with blood off the gunfire and first
police sirens could be heard across the
city the Mandalay Hotel is the tall
building in the distance the gunman was
on the 32nd floor we saw something that
looked like fireworks it sounded like
fireworks over the side it was like
really weird and it was like why are
they doing the fireworks and it popped a
couple of times and people kind of
looked over and you could see smoke or
something it was toward Mandalay Bay
side and and and then we saw Jason run
off stage and then people all over on
the floor the grassy area in front of
the stage were just like somewhere
falling and some were screaming and
yelling and running and we were in this
tower up on top and it's like everyone
said to hit the floor so everyone was
just like literally laying on top of
each other trying to get out of the way
and the shots just kept coming and so we
were going down and when we got down
there was a man that was shot right
there they were trying to take him out
he was all bloody and he was unconscious
and one of my friends was helping him
out and they got him out and we ran and
everybody's hiding everywhere I mean
they're hiding under the bleachers and
the stanchions and anywhere they could
and everyone's telling us to run run as
fast as you can my husband and I ran out
toward our car and there were people
hiding underneath my car for cover and
there was a a gentleman that was shot
and he said can you help me and so I put
him in my car and I had like six people
in my car people with out shoes
running just to get away and the
Mandalay Bay Hotel is on the southern
end of Las Vegas is famous strip the
road was locked down as the police
secured the area the nearby
International Airport was closed and
flights stopped for a few hours tourists
and residents were ordered to stay
inside SWAT teams moved in and
surrounded the gunman in his hotel room
onions on the 32nd floor
what has explosive breach everyone in
the hall I needs to move back reach
Bruce Bruce he shot himself dead before
they managed to break the door down this
is footage of that corridor shortly
after that all happened the gunman has
been named as Steven paddock more than
10 guns were found in his hotel room his
motive is still unknown US officials
have said that it is not connected to
international terrorism but Islamic
state has claimed responsibility and
that claim is now being looked into Las
Vegas police gave televised updates
every couple of hours each time
delivering the grim news that the number
of dead a number of injured was rising
individuals that were attending the
festival the number is estimated to be
22,000 were being struck by those rounds
currently the Clark County Fire
Department is estimating the injuries to
be well over 400 and the deaths
associated with this event to be over 50
I can't give you an exact number yet
because we're still investigating some
of the areas involving the event where
the concert was taking place and we're
still exiting individuals that were
hidden and it's just a matter of a
process in the moments after the attack
police released details of this woman
believed to have been paddocks roommate
she is no longer a suspect in the
investigation though we have located her
out of the country she was not with him
when he checked in we have discovered he
was utilizing some of her identification
and we have had conversation with her
and we believed her at this time not to
be involved but obviously that will be
that investigation will continue as dawn
broke on the west coast the president
gave a live statement into America's
breakfast shows to have found the
shooter so quickly after the first shots
were fired is something for which we
will always be thankful and grateful
it shows what true professionalism is
all about hundreds of our fellow
citizens are now mourning the sudden
loss of a loved one a parent a child a
brother or sister we cannot fathom their
pain we cannot imagine their loss to the
families of the victims we are praying
for you and we are here for you and we
ask God to help see you through this
very dark period scripture teaches us
the Lord is close to the brokenhearted
and saves those who are crushed in
spirit we seek comfort in those words
for we know that God lives in the hearts
of those who grieve to the wounded who
are now recovering in hospitals we are
praying for your full and speedy
recovery and pledge to you our support
from this day forward it was a speech
heavy on religious sentiment but it
lacked any reference to America's gun
laws inevitably that debate will be had
again especially because product might
have used automatic weapons I believe
there were some weapons found and maybe
some ammunition as far as what type or
how many I can't give that information
out cuz I don't know it that information
will have to come through the Las Vegas
metropolitan police department at the
Las Vegas hotel now in daylight you
concede to smashed windows on the 32nd
floor used by Steven paddock to fire on
the crowd below him his family say they
are as confused as everyone else
there's just nothing is all in the
public record he did stuff we want to
call it she had a job you know we own
some apartments we sold some apartments
sweet I mean there's there's nothing and
there was no nothing
that's what's so I mean I mean I can't
even make something up there's just
there's nothing I'm
I mean once again I mean our condolences
I mean you know could have been my kids
at that show I mean you know cetera et
cetera
I don't know what else to say were Las
Vegas hospitals are busy with the
hundreds injured authorities have asked
people to donate blood a location set up
especially around the city there was a
minute's silence before trading began at
the New York Stock Exchange flags across
the United States have been lowered to
half-mast the world reacted this was an
individual shooting randomly a
completely senseless and cowardly attack
and so many people have been killed and
injured and our thoughts and prayers are
with all those who have been victims of
this terrible attack in the coming hours
the death toll might rise further still
the names and pictures and stories of
those who died will be released it is a
familiar pattern a tragic routine that
America is used to although never on
this scale